okay let's speak to some people uh we do
now
speak to folks through the david pakman
show discord which now has i don't know
12
13 14 000 people subscribed to it you
can find it at davidpakman.com
discord let's start today with
stevie from asheville stevie from
asheville you were on the air
what's going on hey david how are you
doing today
i'm doing well thank you no thank you
yeah it's funny i woke up like 15
minutes ago
and i'm still waking up but i saw you
were doing this and i'm
well hopefully awake enough to have a
coherent question
yes yes sir all right so my question for
you
is what do you make of all this pipeline
issues that's happening
i i live in you know asheville north
carolina and we're seeing
long lines at the gas stations there's
hardly gas
anywhere when is this going to end david
from what i'm reading this is going to
be resolved
possibly by the end of this weekend uh i
mean
i don't know that i have any more
up-to-date information than you have
okay how do you think joe biden and his
administration are going to
respond to this i've heard that there's
uh i guess
there's i don't know if it's a
conspiracy or if it's confirmed that
this was from russia
i have not heard that uh what i have
heard was that it is related to
um the method of attack was
cyber but i and i may just be behind on
the issue i've not even heard it
asserted that it was russia so i would
want to look into that
uh but i think that the biden
administration response will depend on
what we ultimately know about it i just
don't know
if that's definitive and i think i want
to be careful about speculating
of course of course are you going out
and like filling
bags with gas like we've seen some
people do
no no i i i thankfully i
i happened to get gas on sunday before
this all happened
so i'm i'm doing well but yeah i know
people are panic um filling up gas i saw
i did see someone i work for a company
where you know we're delivery and we i
saw people filling up canisters
three four five at a time yeah it's
actually ridiculous
i saw one video of a woman filling up a
plastic bag with gas and it's like once
you get it into the car what do you like
when you're holding the bag in the air
that could work
but then how do you set it down it just
didn't really make any it
from the standpoint of um of mechanical
physics i wasn't understanding it
yeah yeah i mean maybe she's come up
with some sort of you know metaphysical
strategy that we're just
not understanding like mere mortals like
us
there was something there that made me
think i may not understand the
principles of solids gases and liquids
yeah i mean yeah she could just be on a
different plane of existence
you know like i i don't know david all
right well
how's vaccination going down there oh
you did good you know i live in
asheville which is kind of
you know it's uh kind of a jewel in the
midst of the south
yeah i'm personally vaccinated myself
beautiful uh both
um yeah yeah so it's going good on my
end um my friends are getting vaccinated
i
apparently the uh um numbers are going
down though
and uh for this for the country and i'm
a little nervous about that
yeah they're going they did but they are
actually taking back up now and with 12
to 15 year olds able to get pfizer i
think
i think we're on the up and up i really
think we're going to be looking pretty
good by memorial day
well david starting off my day that's
wonderful news because i've been
ignoring it
pleasure pleasure i got a little a
little scared a little nervous but
you know all right my friend i
appreciate the calls uh thank you
thank you david take care all right so a
big issue
gasoline still necessary for so much of
our daily life
if you ever feel like you just don't
have enough time to read all the books
you want to read
you have to check out one of my favorite
apps called blinkist blinkist takes
thousands of popular nonfiction books
and distills
each one down into an e-book or
audiobook
that you can get through in just 15
minutes where you're getting all the key
takeaways from the book
just imagine how you'll be able to
expand your horizons and knowledge
by being able to soak up all of the
important insights from
10 different books in an afternoon
obviously it's perfect for exposing
yourself to a new book
you otherwise wouldn't have time for or
you can use it to revisit a book you've
already read
or use it to preview a book before you
buy the full version and read it
i recently read a brief history of time
of course by the great
stephen hawking this is a book that i
have been aware of for so long
and other things got in the way and it
was fantastic
to check it out on blinkist blinkist has
books on politics philosophy
science they have 27 different
non-fiction categories and a
subscription is only about eight bucks a
month
and you get the entire library but
you can try it totally free and get 25
off a subscription
when you go to blinkist.com pacman
i've put the link right underneath this
video